you know who's out you typically had a
chance to make the playoffs typically
got a chance to go deep into the
playoffs or teams that start 3-0 usually
around like 2-0 is one thing sucking
three you know that starts to really put
you in a good position gives you a nice
head start
uh who is the most impressive 3-0 team
we've got six teams so far the
three-and-oh we'll have a seventh after
the game tonight
barring a tie uh who is your most
impressive three-no team to this point
i would say the most unlikely the most
unlikely
3-0 team is buffalo
we'll get to them buffalo and the bears
right
uh i know what you're answering the
bears i know your answer is not the
bears it's your most important
right i guess yeah
i can make an argument
for my reasons
they're regressing to the mean i know
that much very quickly you missed that
they missed that i said i said
not even done chicago though great great
city great city chicago but i'm gonna
say the most impressive team
three-and-oh
is is seattle because they can't be
stopped on one hand their defense you
should be concerned because they haven't
given up fewer than 30 yet
three games in
but nobody can stop him like russell
wilson is just
russell wilson is on something else and
so
you go in there you go in there saying
we can't let russell do this he can't
let russell do that and he does it
anyway
i think that's the most impressive 3-0
team how about you
green bay
and not just because they want at new
orleans or what what passes for at new
orleans to your point earlier
green bay is scary man because it's
unstoppable as seattle's been green bay
scored more
green may score more now if you want to
talk about
quality opponents
i think dallas is decent
um
you know because dallas could have come
into that game yesterday 2-0 so seattle
now has wins over
new england and dallas in consecutive
weeks something to be said
hey who else
i'll get to him in a second the team the
t-net shall not be named i'll get to
them in a second we'll get something we
got to talk about them i can't wait to
talk about them
yeah and i know green bay they beat you
they beat your bears
uh no that's your bears no i'm sorry
they beat the lions and the vikings
sorry they didn't play the bishop fight
lions and the vikings
uh but last night i think you saw it
without devante adams without devonte
adams listen man
aaron rodgers has never looked
uncomfortable in his entire career but
there was always a part of us that
wondered i don't like mike mccarthy but
always a part of us and especially
packers fans that wonder
like man could they get out of the stone
age with this offense like could they be
more creative on offense could they put
aaron in better positions in terms of
his play calling aaron rodgers is going
out of his way to shout out matt lafleur
bruh look at these dudes he was throwing
to last night
yeah look at these cats they throw into
last night
alan lazard robert tanyan that first
round pick is on the bench taking notes
sitting behind him for the indefinite
future
aaron rodgers is more
comfortable
in this offense than he was last year
when he went 13-3 and a lot of people
didn't think they were as good as their
record you know suggested last year now
he's more comfortable that should make
the entire league uncomfortable the idea
of aaron rodgers being even better so
it's like yeah we're giving mvp to
russell wilson and rightfully so we got
14 touchdowns and three games for crying
out loud throws five touchdowns a week
it's incredible um
we're giving mvp to russell wilson
but remember i keep telling you you
tried to leave him out it's like best
quarterbacks in the league it's wilson
the homes i'm like and aaron rodgers and
aaron rodgers i hope you stayed up late
i know you're old i know it's past your
bedtime i hope you stayed up late to
watch that man at the fool last night
because he still got it and he still may
have some of his best days and games
ahead of him
given how scary stacked this offense is
no
devonta adams last night and cooked the
cook the saints
i like your little shots today that's
good you know that's good i i got it i i
got the shot that's that stayed up late
uh you probably weren't bad at t you
probably didn't funny i struggle i
struggle i know you do
but you know aaron rodgers is this is an
interesting view if you compare seattle
and green bay
the reason i say seattle i'll give
seattle the edge
is it's almost like
you know russell wilson had to just wait
a couple of years for pete carroll to
say all right i'm going to give the
office
yeah yeah yeah go ahead i'm going to
give it to you because we had to hear
about the legion of boom for a while
then we had to hear about the running
game eventually eventually they figured
out
hey our quarterback is pretty good too
and same
kind of like the same story with the
receivers in the early days now you get
a lot of respect to the receivers that
russell has but uh back in the day you'd
look at him yeah three four years ago
and you look at his receiving corps and
say okay that's not that great
they eventually trusted him so now they
got what eight years together between
russell and carol
eight years of work and i think the only
advantage i'll give him i'll give wilson
over rogers
is at eight years of trust
with his head coach because maybe what
matt lafleur is going to figure out yeah
but but pete carol ain't calling the
plays though that's the only thing i
would i would beg to differ on be
careful okay like this the sympotico is
not as essential between russell wilson
and pete carroll as it is between aaron
rodgers and matt but at least i mean
you've been around the guy the head
coach you've been around her for eight
years you just kind of know what you can
and can't do but i would say with
leflore
and he may know that now and if he
doesn't know it now he'll find it out
pretty soon the great thing about aaron
rodgers is you install
a shell of an offense i think that's the
best way to do it with him hey here's
here's generally what we're trying to do
he seems to me to be a good improviser
you'd be a good freestyler like that's
what he does so give him like the shell
of an offense
and then don't trip
when he when it kind of breaks down and
he does something else and that was the
problem with mccarthy and rogers in the
end the last two or three years
maybe they've been together too long but
aaron rodgers kind of lost some faith in
mccarthy and mccarthy was probably
aghast that aaron rodgers wouldn't run
his plays and so they kind of butted
heads that's the only advantage
russell wilson has right now but
who knows that might not even be the
case uh november 1st mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports